こんにちははじめ社長です
あの
重い版女子になるかもしれないんですけども
いろいろ一応話し合い的に解決はしてないんですけど1話はついてるんで
そんな心配しないで下さいまあこういうことがあってということですあの最近よろし
公開まして
めっちゃ入って行ったらいいなあの僕は最近目がいろんなことを考えてちょっと趣向が
変わってきたんですけど何て言うんでしょ
思ったことだかなんか自分が言いたいことは作るわずにちゃんと
8日な通って膝龍の剣とかそういう感じですねちょっとあの今後ちゃんと思ったことと
か
もうちょっと自分に正直になってちょっと自由に動画を作っていきたいと思います始め
社長ですはいというでもタイトル見てびっくりしたとんですけどもあのがちですあの
twitter で殺害予告をされました
あのちょっとツリーみたいなんじゃなくて結構ガチでえっと一応も静岡警察家の前の
警察署と最初に通報が入ったら京都の警察署かな京都警察も一応は動いていただいて
おりましても今操作していただいているという状況でございますあ詳しくどうまでされ
てるかわかんないんですけどもじゃあ当事者としてそういうことがされているというの
は聞きました
いやーん
なんでしたねとっていうのはすぐわかるもんで大もう年齢とかバトル時犯人のちょっと
だける情報たって奴見たらすぐどの人もわかるんですけど
f 平成13年生まれの男性だということはも分かっておりますでただ滋賀県にお
住まいなのかな
現在は分からないんですけどなんか僕でたらちょっと白そこに出てきているしもう警察
の方にも聞いたんですけど
警察園の方でももう
れてのめどは立ってるらしいでございます今ちょっとまあネットだと話題ですねその
誹謗中傷が良くないぞっていうのはもちろん僕は悪いことだと思うんですけども7発年
前からね熱湯で活動してる男からするとね今更に始まったことじゃないなと思うんです
けど
まあもうそれの道こすってますね今回はもう殺人予告その twitter ご覧
くださいこちら
もう冗談でもこういうことを言っちゃいけませんはい8月に都内のどこかでテロを
起こしますさと邪魔したら代わりに弾みやるよ
全部アウトも普通に行った分捕まりますすいません
何度で頑張ってね駄目で本当にこういうことしちゃなんじゃ俺がちょっとを曲げみたい
なってんでふざけてマジで何で僕もこれに気づいたかと言いますとゆっくんこれ大丈夫
みたいなこういうことをされてますけど本当に大丈夫ですかっていうのが来て気づいて
まぁこちらですねちょっと今から殺しに行ってやるよ
トップ殺したらさだが勝利は有名人だろうなあの皆さん覚えておいてくださいトップ名
でもつい
たんでこういう殺人予告とか殺すぞとかこれは完全にアウトでございます僕が事件化し
たらも普通にこず保つ変わりません特定されてトップメディアってもねあのスマホの
情報とか色々も出てるんでもう1回説明からも終わりだと思ってください多分普通に
捕まりますねまあもちろんこれはダメなんですけどもこれだけじゃなくてその次がもう
ね衝撃的だったんです
やっと着いた今から信じてやるはしにハッシュタグ始めたつをハッシュタグはじめしね
まあ僕ん家の写真でございますこれがちょっとまあ決めてるしたね警察の方を動かす
さっきのついただけでも全然もじゃないんですけどこれマジで俺んちの前にいるっぽい
んですよ
分かんだねサーのどこがの広いが立ったとしても家の前にいる可能性があるんだったら
もう動く
人たちは動いちゃうんでこれで確信してあの今回僕から警察に通報したわけじゃなくて
他の誰か2そうしてくださっ
で動いて僕の方に夢の中来て子供操作をお願いしますという感じで流したんですけども
ここまでやっちゃうともう取り返しがつきませんでいつも12件のリツイートとか結構
いろんな方の目にとまってるん
んでー
もう救いようがありませんでも僕も強かったんだ夜中の3時に警察の方がきてなんか俺
最近めっちゃ事件にか絡まれてねーお酒治安が悪いんですけど始めるとこういうことを
軽い気持ちになる人も1人とも減ればいいなと思ってちょっと言いますちょっとネット
で行きがありたかったのか知らないですまれないだろうと9面で大丈夫だろう
風に札をなら何かから影響ずいるしてくれた
ろうと思ったすけど僕は言い出したの警察とか社会は許してくれません
その次もですねうな重を超えて食べてて5年刺さってないて寝ようとしているツイート
に対してそれで死んでくれたら良かったのにが入れたくても君の選んだ薩摩せいで入れ
ないよいった一台あればさしたるからちょっと本当にこれ見た瞬間俺もちょっとやばい
なって思っちゃって多分本当に鬱の前で計画の方がいらっしゃったんです
その雑行まで把握してるから多分本当にいらっしゃったのかなって僕は思ってしまい
ました
何でも深夜ず警察の方が見張ってくださってたみたいなんですけどねこういう顔わから
ないツイート一つですごい御膳を大人が動いてしまっている
大迷惑なことをしている子たちと理解した方がいいと思いますねこの人のツイート見
てるので結構
スミヤバイこと言ってるんでしょそれも何かある時を境にそれまで普通の人だったし何
か僕にもなんだ普通にリップいで送ってきてくれてるんでしょフツーなよー
いやもうねんかね最近のニュースとかで誹謗中傷がどうこうとかネットとかで何か活躍
されたり頑張ってる人に向かって
そんな批判的になるみたいな人が多かったりすごいなんか
最近そういうの多いじゃないですかなくそれを見てずっとで鶏カツする僕が思ったこと
はなんか誰かも言ってましたけどもっと自分のために時間使ったらいいのにって思い
ますね
結局あの人の批判とかさそんな人のことをとやかく言うんだったらもっと自分のために
なることをすればいいのになって思うし僕ももちろん今まで結構
もうほんとボロくと言われたとき
とかめっちゃくちゃ暴言言われまくった時とかあったんですけどもこちらがはもう見
なきゃいいだけなんで
僕も見たらもちろん傷つきますけれども見なければ何も情報が入ってこないし反応し
なければいいんですけどもやっぱりそれでもどうしても家にしちゃったり生地に見
ちゃって来ず方もいらっしゃるんで亡くなった方がいいとは思いますけれども
今回それのモードが過ぎた
日本最骨頂ですこちら殺人予告立派な犯罪でございます
しっかりと私は警察どう動いて本当にめちゃ曲の訳詞たんでちゃんとこういうことをし
たらどうなるかっていうのちょっとわかってもらいたいと私を持っておりますでもその
警察の方が操作してるって言って結構も23日たっても何もなかったんでこっちから
できることなんだろうと思ってちょっと dm を送ってみたんですよまず
帰ってくれが道がわからなかったのであって送ってみました
そしたらあって帰ってきましたまだ会話できるんだったらなんか高校生できる余地が
ないかなと思ってあああああいうつが行かないですよって泥をしたら
帰ってこなくなったっていうところでございます今はいという話があればスターの
とりあえず
のに何が
ウッドでサブ垢とが裏がとか作って自分でバレないように何かに向かって攻撃したり音
がめっちゃ春愚痴ってみたり知ったらそれだけで室に誰かバレちゃってさっきありませ
んそのアイドルの誰かがそれを訴えようとしてその示談金に300万円くらいだったか
なそれが請求されたというのもありました気がします
よく知らないですけどなんかなんかね
なんかねもうちょっと頭使いなって思っちゃいますねこういうことする人やわからんだ
俺もうちょっと無意識で誰かを傷つけている可能性もあるからあんまり得ないことは
言えないんですけども度が過ぎたそういう音誰かを超攻撃するような内容とかは要ら
ない方がいいです匿名でも影気持ちで行ったほうがいいですあのまず普通に何百万とか
請求来ますから是非
皆さんお気を付け下さいいやもんで気持ちはわかるよ
声5時ででも外にも出れないで縮小樹縮小
技めちゃな世界でもうすっごいだするのはわかるんですけどもこういう時だからこそは
みんなでネットで繋がって pot ポジティブなものにしていかなきゃいけないのか
なって思います何で足の引っ張り合いすすめのネットで剥がして誰か回転な気持ちに
なってさあその1
潰してなんかあーだこーだいその一粒それの繰り返しというのはずっとなんか最近多い
んで何かもっとサーボという有意義なっていうか自分のプラスになるようなネットの
使い方をしてはいかがでしょうか
という僕もねなんかこういうことを言うとこのツイッターに殺人予告した人になかっ
たら色々いう方がいらっしゃると思うんですよねそこもちょっとどうなると思う方も
いらっしゃると思うけどもう
ネットに年 twitter とかって潰れちゃうとが原因でも見られる世界なんで逆
に言うとそうローンを誰がどう見ても悪いことをつぶやいとり発生したとそれはもう
言われるのは仕方ないことだと思いますある程度は見てるかは右腕がも誹謗痛症とか気
をつけなきゃいけないし発信それがもういやそれはどうみてもダメでしょっていうこと
を教
誓なきゃいけないなって思いますめっちゃ真面目まじめですけど魔女んですけども本当
にこの4連休とかも東京の方とかで縮小ってし家にいるのがベストだと思うんでどうか
イライラをね人にぶつけるんじゃなくて何か別の本にぶつけたりいかがでしょうか
とりあえず警察の方家の前までこれで殺人予告をされました
カカオなちゃん
あっは
[音楽]
bl